In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 30th, on which we commemorate, the Holy Martyr
Jolita of Cessaria.
Saint Jolita was a rich widow of Cessaria in Cappadocia during the time of the persecution
under Diocletian, a leading figure in the city, a man without scruples,
full of cupidity and violent, succeeded in seizing the major part of her estate, fields,
villages, cattle and slaves, and disdaining all justice, he did not hesitate to use
Columny and false witnesses to bribe the judges to achieve his ends and to reduce her
to complete penury.
A court case was begun, and when it became clear that Jolita's rights were about to be
recognized, he accused her of being a Christian, which, according to the edict, recently promulgated
by the emperor in the year 303, deprived her of all civil rights.
The judge immediately ordered that incense and an altar be brought, and that Jolita
offer sacrifice to the gods of the empire so that she might enjoy the protection of the
law.
Without hesitation, the saint wisely realizing that it would be the height of folly to
renounce eternal life in order to save her corruptible possessions, declared, then let
it all be lost, let this life disappear, and all the glory and wealth of this world,
for nothing would make me deny my creator and my God, who created all things.
When no argument was found to make her change her mind, and when she continued to respond
to all propositions by repeating, I am a servant of Christ.
It was decided to burn her alive.
Jolita went to the flames with a joyful ardor, exhorting the Christian women along the
way to the pyre, saying, We too, like men, are created in the image of God.
Virtue is possible for women, as well as for men.
Fresh of the flesh of Adam, bone of his bone, we must offer constancy, courage, virility,
and a long suffering endurance to the Lord.
Arriving at the place of execution, she mounted the pyre as though she were entering a light-filled
bridal chamber.
The flames seized hold of her, and her soul took flight to the Lord, while her body remained
intact and unharmed, a preliminary sign of the incorruptibility promised to the elect.
Later, in the atrium of the Basilica built over the sight of her martyrdom, which was the
most beautiful church in the city, a fountain, giving forth water with healing properties,
miraculously, spring forth.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.